you know I haven't seen you since Trump
got elected only enough yeah I know I
don't really since since that and you
know obviously the show is very Trump
oriented yeah you do your thing because
it's what people are talking about it's
all anybody talks right it's almost like
no other news is happening well he's the
biggest news that's happening he's the
biggest news so I'm imagining because I
see it on my show if I say anything
slightly negative about Trump slightly
negative yeah a fans will call in and go
would you [ __ ] stop talking about
politics right would you cut the [ __ ]
already
everyone thinks in terms of either your
for Trump or against Trump now with you
being like so forcefully but your comedy
is brutal
yeah about Trump he even calls you out
about it yeah are you threatened at all
do people get emotional with you do they
do they start screaming at you if you go
out to a restaurant no I mean let's be
honest I live in Manhattan which is a
liberal town yeah but also you know I do
feel like because we've been very open
about what our show is right I think if
you love Donald Trump you've probably
chosen to disengage with the show is
most of the writing between the
monologue and closer look is that is
that you doing most of the writing we
have a monologue team and then we have a
head writer for a closer look who's this
really brilliant writer named Saladin
field it must be an amazing day I mean
the day has to start early well today
the next three days will be crazy
because we have basically we can't write
ahead of time like there's gonna be
impeachment hearings all day today all
day tomorrow all day Thursday yeah so
what do you do
we basically watch and write in real
time you ever think like the president
United States is gonna try to get you
feel like he's angrier about SNL now
than me
you know what I mean yeah but he's angry
with you he's tweeted about you yes but
not for a while I think like he he's
angrier at SNL because they I feel like
to him they it's a betrayal right
because he was on it yeah did you you
were there when he was on it right first
time 2004 did you enjoy working with him
I mean it was it was fascinating to be
around him would he come into writing
meetings no no no it's too big he was
just a you know he was everything you
would think he didn't have any sense of
humor right but if things worked he
liked them
and by work did you have to explain to
him why they worked yeah and even then
it was the way the audience respond it
was only the it's the way it's the same
way he is in rallies now you know it's
right
he keeps saying build the wall because
it worked right so in other words you
write a sketch for him he doesn't get it
yeah but he'd go out and dress and all
of a sudden people are laughing yeah
she's like there's sometimes you have a
host where a sketch bombs but they love
it and they say let's do it it's so
great that it's not him no he wants to
win yeah just it's just how it went